Hey there, Shankar here with a quick note before we start today's show. I'm bringing Hidden Brain to the stage in San Francisco and Seattle in February 2025. I'll share seven psychological insights from the last decade of hosting Hidden Brain. Each insight has made my life better, and I think it will do the same for you. Please join me for an evening of science and storytelling. More information and a link to tickets is at hiddenbrain.org.org. That's hiddenbrain.org. All attendees receive one year's complimentary membership to the Meditation and Sleep app, Calm. Hope to see you there. Again, go to hiddenbrain.org. This is Hidden
大家好，我是香卡，在今天的節目開始前先跟大家說個消息。2025年2月，我將帶著《隱性大腦》登上舊金山和西雅圖的舞台。我將分享過去十年主持《隱性大腦》所獲得的七個心理學洞見。每一個洞見都讓我的生活變得更好，我相信對你也會有所幫助。請和我一起度過一個充滿科學與故事的夜晚。更多資訊和購票連結請至 hiddenbrain.org。網址是 hiddenbrain.org。所有與會者都將獲得冥想與睡眠應用程式 Calm 的一年期免費會員資格。希望在那裡見到你。再次提醒，請造訪 hiddenbrain.org。這是《隱性》
to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedant. The biblical King Solomon is said to have constructed a religious edifice nearly 3,000 years ago. Accounts of the Temple of Solomon, largely drawn from the Hebrew Bible, say that Solomon placed an object of incalculable value within a windowless room of the temple. It was the Ark of the Covenant, a wooden chest decorated with gold. Inside it were tablets given to Moses by God inscribed with the Ten Commandments.
請至 hiddenbrain.org 瀏覽巡演資訊。這裡是《隱性大腦》，我是香卡·維丹坦。據說聖經中的所羅門王大約在3000年前建造了一座宗教建築。關於所羅門聖殿的記載大多出自《希伯來聖經》，其中提到所羅門將一件價值無法估量的物品放置在聖殿無窗的房間裡。這就是約櫃，一個飾有黃金的木製箱子。裡面裝著上帝賜予摩西、刻有十誡的石板。
Remnants or artifacts from the temple have never been found. Remnants or artifacts from the temple have never been found. About 300 years ago, the Temple of Solomon became a subject of intense interest to a gifted mathematician in England. Isaac Newton came to believe that biblical accounts of the temple contained messages and clues that could be mathematically decoded. He also felt the temple's architecture contained geometrical secrets and a blueprint of human history. Based on his calculations and deductions, he predicted a major event in the 21st century, one that some people took to mean the end of the world as we know it. Even as he dabbled in what would now be considered the occult, Isaac Newton also famously revolutionized
人們從未找到過這座聖殿的殘垣或古物。人們從未找到過這座聖殿的殘垣或古物。大約300年前，所羅門聖殿成為英國一位才華橫溢的數學家深入研究的對象。艾薩克·牛頓漸漸相信，聖經對聖殿的記載中包含了可以透過數學解碼的訊息和線索。他還認為聖殿的建築蘊含著幾何祕密和人類歷史的藍圖。根據他的計算和推論，他預測了21世紀將發生一件大事，有些人認為這意味著我們所熟知世界末日。儘管牛頓涉足了現在被認為是神秘學的領域，但他也以徹底革新
our understanding of the physical world. He came up with laws of physics that are still taught in high schools today. His contributions to mathematics, especially the science of calculus, are used on a daily basis in fields as diverse as space travel and epidemiology. How did the scientist who helped us understand the law of gravity come to believe he had special powers to decode scripture? Why did one of the most influential mathematicians in history spend so many years trying to turn base metals into gold?
我們對物理世界的理解而聞名。他提出的物理定律至今仍在中學教授。他對數學的貢獻，特別是微積分學，在太空旅行和流行病學等截然不同的領域中被日常使用。這個幫助我們理解重力定律的科學家，怎麼會相信自己擁有解讀經文的特殊能力呢？歷史上最具影響力的數學家之一，為什麼會花這麼多年試圖把卑金屬變成黃金？
It's easy to say Isaac Newton was being brilliant when he was inventing calculus, and foolish when he dabbled in the occult. The truth was that Isaac Newton saw both of these as forms of exploration. It's just that we know that one turned out to be right, and the other turned out to be wrong. Today, we're going to tell you the story of another explorer. He was a psychologist who wanted to answer big questions. But in trying to do so, he dreamed up
我們很容易說，艾薩克·牛頓發明微積分時是個天才，而涉足神秘學時則是個傻瓜。事實是，艾薩克·牛頓把這兩者都看作是探索的形式。只是我們知道，其中一個結果證明是對的，而另一個結果證明是錯的。今天，我們要告訴大家另一個探險家的故事。他是一位想要解答宏大問題的心理學家。但在嘗試這樣做的過程中，他構想出了
one of the most notorious experiments of the 20th century and inadvertently became the poster child for the human weaknesses he was trying to study. What I try to do is create evil. It's really studying evil from the inside out. The Risks of Exploration and the Lessons of Hindsight, this week on Hidden Brain.
20世紀最惡名昭著的實驗之一，並不經意間成為了他試圖研究的人類弱點的活靶子。我試圖做的是製造邪惡。這其實是從內到外研究邪惡。探索的風險與事後諸葛的教訓，本週《隱性大腦》。
In February 1933, shortly after Adolf Hitler was appointed Chancellor of Germany, a fire broke out in the Reichstag building, home to the German parliament. The Nazis cited the fire as proof that communists were planning a violent takeover of the country. The solution they proposed was to suspend the constitution, declare emergency rule, and bring an end to civil rights. It paved the way for Adolf Hitler to become the dictator of Germany. A month after the Reichstag fire, a baby boy was born in the South Bronx to a family of Italian origin.
1933年2月，就在阿道夫·希特勒被任命為德國總理後不久，德國議會所在地國會大廈發生了一場大火。納粹將這場大火引為共產黨正計劃暴力奪取國家政權的證據。他們提出的解決方案是中止憲法、宣布進入緊急狀態，並終結公民權利。這為阿道夫·希特勒成為德國獨裁者鋪平了道路。國會大廈縱火案發生一個月後，一個男嬰在南布朗克斯的一個義大利裔家庭出生。
My parents were second generation Sicilian. My family background was my grandfather was a barber, my other grandfather was a shoemaker. So it was really, you know, tradespeople. This is Philip Zimbardo. In time, he was to become one of the most influential psychologists of the 20th century, and much of his life's work would attempt to understand how Adolf Hitler and the Nazis came to transform the minds
我的父母是第二代西西里人。我的家庭背景是，我外公是個理髮師，我另一個外公是個鞋匠。所以這真是一個，你知道的，工匠家庭。這是菲利普·津巴多。假以時日，他將成為20世紀最具影響力的心理學家之一，他一生的大部分工作都將試圖理解阿道夫·希特勒和納粹是如何改變
of ordinary Germans. But in 1933, Philip's family was not thinking about Nazi Germany. It was the height of the Great Depression. In the United States, nearly a quarter of all workers were unemployed. Some people were living in shanty towns, while others were on the move, desperate to find work. In addition to coming from a poor family, Philip was prone to deadly illnesses. When I was a child I was very sickly, in fact I almost
普通德國人的思想的。但在1933年，菲利普的家庭並沒有考慮納粹德國。那是經濟大蕭條的高峰期。在美國，近四分之一的工人失業。有些人住在貧民窟裡，而另除了來自貧困家庭，菲利普還容易生致命的疾病。我小時候非常多病，事實上我差點
died from pneumonia and whooping cough at a time when there was no penicillin or sulfur drugs for contagious diseases. So I was hospitalized for six months and kids around me all died and I survived somehow. Resilience or hardiness, I'm not sure what. Young Philip wasn't seen as resilient or hardy by the other kids in his neighborhood. They looked at this kid who had escaped a brush with death and saw a weakling, someone who could be pushed around. When I came out of the hospital because I was really sick,
死於肺炎和百日咳，當時沒有青黴素或磺胺類藥物來治療傳染病。所以我住院了六個月，我周圍的孩子都死了，而我不知怎的活了下來。是韌性還是堅強，我不太確定。年輕的菲利普在鄰里其他孩子眼中並不被認為是堅韌或頑強的。他們看著這個從死神手中逃脫的孩子，看到的是一個弱者，一個可以被人欺負的人。當我出院時，因為我真的很病，
I used to get beaten up all the time, also because I looked Jewish. And then I realized that the world is made up of leaders and followers, and followers are going to get beaten up. So I really, as a 6, 7, ten-year-old kid, started trying to understand what was it about some kids who got to be leaders. And I think I figured out a kind of recipe.
我以前總是挨打，也因為我看起來像猶太人。然後我意識到，世界是由領袖和追隨者組成的，而追隨者是要挨打的。所以大約在6、7歲、十歲的時候，我真的開始試圖理解，為什麼有些孩子能成為領袖。我想我摸索出了一種秘訣。
They were bigger, they were the first ones to talk up, they usually had a joke, they usually had a big, stronger guy backing them up, and they always gave the group some interesting activities. Philip was not yet a psychologist, but already he was coming up with psychological theories about the world. In what was to become a hallmark of his future career, he came up with bold, intuitive leaps to explain the world he saw. And even as he engaged in the rites and rituals of childhood, there was always a part of his mind that played the observer, that watched himself engage in those rites and rituals. Philip noticed there were things you had to do to become accepted into
他們更大隻，他們是第一個開口說話的人，他們通常會講個笑話，通常背後都有一個身材魁梧、更強壯的傢伙支持他們，而且他們總是給團隊提供一些有趣的活動。菲利普當時還不是心理學家，但他已經開始對世界提出心理學理論。正如他未來職業生涯的標誌一樣，他提出了大膽、直覺的飛躍來解釋他所看到的世而甚至在他參與童年的儀式和規矩時，他的腦海中總有一部分在扮演旁觀者，觀察自己參與那些儀式和規矩。菲利普注意到，有些事情你必須去做才能被
a group. In order to get into the gang, and the gang was the kids on the block, the newest kid had to physically fight the most recent kid who was in the gang until one of you got a bloody nose. And I hated violence. I could see it's the stupidness of these kind of rituals. Philip also noticed how hierarchy worked in groups. Some kids give orders, some kids follow orders. And I thought, you know, typically orders they follow are stupid. But once you get used to that, it becomes a habit.
群體接受。為了加入幫派——幫派就是街區裡的孩子們——最新的孩子必須和幫派裡最近加入的孩子打架，直到其中一人流鼻血。而我討厭暴力。我能看出這類儀式有多愚蠢。菲利普還注意到階級如何在群體中運作。有些孩子發號施令，有些孩子聽從命令。我心想，你知道的，他們聽從的命令通常都很愚蠢。但一旦你習慣了，它就變成了一種習慣。
If some kids were going to give stupid orders and some kids were going to follow them, Philip realized he much preferred to be in the first group. He decided he would study the tricks and techniques leaders used to get to the top. He set to work developing those habits. But it was really structuring situations, being the one that came up with the new idea to say, hey, marble season should be always boring, why don't we do stickball?
如果有些孩子要發號施令，有些孩子要聽從命令，菲利普意識到他更願意成為第一組的人。他決定研究領袖們用來登上頂峰的把戲和技巧。他開始著手培養這些習慣。但這實際上是建構情境，成為想出新點子的人，比如嘿，彈珠季節總是很無聊，我們為什麼不玩棒球呢？
So essentially it's coming up with the idea of what to do that other kids would say, yeah, that's interesting, let's do it. It worked. Philip shed his image as a sickly kid. He became an athlete, excelling in track, softball, and baseball. He was voted the most popular kid in his high school class. But there was another realm where Philip realized he could not outshine the competition. That's because the competition, when it came to being the smartest kid in class,
所以本質上就是想出該做什麼的點子，讓其他孩子會說，好吧，這很有趣，我們來玩吧。這奏效了。菲利普擺脫了病弱少年的形象。他成了一名運動員，在田徑、壘球和棒球方面表現出色。他被選為高中班上最受歡迎的孩子。但還有另一個領域，菲利普意識到自己無法在競爭中勝過別人。那是因為在成為班上最聰明的孩子這項競爭中，
was no competition at all. A kid named Stanley had run off with those honors, and there was absolutely no catching him. He won all the medals at graduation, so obviously nobody liked him because we were all envious of him. But he was super smart and super serious. That Stanley was Stanley Milgram, who just happened to be another famous psychologist of the 20th century.
根本毫無勝算。一個叫斯坦利的男孩搶走了這些榮譽，而且絕對追不上他。他在畢業時贏得了所有的獎牌，所以顯然沒有人喜歡他，因為我們都嫉妒他。但他超級聰明，也超級嚴肅。那個斯坦利就是斯坦利·米爾格拉姆，他恰好是20世紀的另一位著名心理學家。
What were the odds that Stanley Milgram and Philip Zimbardo would be classmates at the same high school in the Bronx? World War II had just ended a few years earlier and the conflict was still fresh in everyone's minds. Philip and Stanley were fascinated and horrified by the Nazi regime's ability to mobilize the German people. How had Adolf Hitler managed to get ordinary Germans to join in the mass extermination of millions of people? Stanley Milgram founded on settling how easily the Nazis managed to associate large groups of people with being inherently different and inferior.
斯坦利·米爾格拉姆和菲利普·津巴多竟然會是布朗克斯同一所高中的同班同學，這機率有多低？第二次世界大戰幾年前才剛剛結束，衝突在每個人腦海中仍然鮮活。菲利普和斯坦利對納粹政權動員德國人民的能力感到著迷又恐懼。阿道夫·希特勒是如何設法讓普通德國人參與對數百万人的大屠殺的？斯坦利·米爾格拉姆發現，納粹竟然能如此輕易地將廣大群體與生俱來的差異和低人一等聯繫起來，這令人不安。
He was worried that the Holocaust could happen again in America. And everybody said, Stanley, that was Nazi Germany, that was then, we're not that kind of people. And he would say, I'll bet they thought the same thing. And the bottom line, he says, how do you know how you would act unless you're in the situation? Because we all think we're good people. We all think we're good people. We all think we're good people, and yet our circumstances can prompt us to do things we might never anticipate.
他擔心大屠殺可能會在美國重演。每個人都說，斯坦利，那是納粹德國，那是過去，我們不是那種人。而他會說，我敢打賭他們當時也是這麼想的。最重要的是，他說，除非你身處那種情境，否則你怎麼知道自己會怎麼做？因為我們都認為自己是好人。我們都認為自己是好人。我們都認為自己是好人，然而我們的環境卻會促使我們做出從未預料到的事。
Philip felt that good kids were not always good, and bad kids were not always bad. It was the situation that made them what they were. If you're middle class, you don't do things for money because your parents give you the money. If you're poor, nobody's going to give you things. So if you want to buy sneakers, then somebody comes on the court and says, hey, carry this package down the other and give it to some guy named Charlie.
菲利普覺得好孩子不總是好的，壞孩子不總是壞的。是情境造就了他們。如果你是中產階級，你不會為了錢做那種事，因為你父母會給你錢。如果你很窮，沒人會給你東西。所以如果你想買運動鞋，然後有人來到球場說，嘿，把這個包裹拿到另一頭去，交給一個叫查理的傢伙。
Well, you knew it had to be something illegal because they're going to give you $10 to carry a package down the street. But you also knew that if you got caught, there would be consequences. And I was tempted. I could use $10. I used to work in a laundry truck, delivering laundry in Harlem. I think we got $2 a day or something. So the temptation is always there. This, of course, is the central claim of the field of social psychology. Our behavior is not just about who we are as people.
好吧，你知道這一定是違法的，因為他們要給你10美元去街上送個包裹。但你也知道，如果被抓到，會有後果的。我當時很心動。我可以用這10美元。我以前在洗衣卡車上工作，在哈萊姆送洗衣物。我想我們一天賺2美元左右。所以誘惑總是存在的。這當然是社會心理學領域的核心主張。我們的行為不只是關於我們作為一個人是誰。
It's a product of who we are as individuals and the situations in which we find ourselves. Stanley Milgram went on to become a psychologist at Yale. Philip Zimbardo became a psychologist at Stanford. As they began their research careers, both men continued to circle the same questions they had asked one another as teenagers. Can you get good people to do terrible things? Are all humans pliable under the right conditions? Do we all have inner monsters just waiting for the right circumstances to be unleashed? Under what conditions would a person obey authority who commanded actions that went against conscience?
它是我們作為個體以及我們所處情境的產物。斯坦利·米爾格拉姆後來成為耶魯大學的心理學家。菲利普·津巴多成為斯坦福大學的心理學家。隨著研究生涯的展開，這兩個人都繼續圍繞著他們青少年時期互相詢問過的問題打轉。你能讓好人做可怕的事嗎？在合適的條件下，所有人類都是溫順的嗎？我們內心深處都有惡魔，只等著合適的環境被釋放出來嗎？在什麼樣的條件下，一個人會服從那些命令他違背良心之事的權威？
These are exactly the questions that I wanted to investigate at Yale University. This is Stanley Milgram in a documentary he later produced about his work. In 1961, he began a series of experiments on obedience. The experiments were set up as a way for one volunteer to help improve the memory of another volunteer. A person in the role of a learner was given a
這些正是我想要在耶魯大學調查的問題。這是斯坦利·米爾格拉姆在他後來製作的關於其工作的紀錄片中所說的。1961年，他開始了一系列關於服從的實驗。這些實驗的設定是讓一個志願者幫助提高另一個志願者的記憶力。扮演學習者角色的個人被給予一份
list of items they had to remember. They would then recite the list to a volunteer who was asked to play the role of teacher. The person running the study told the teacher that every time the learner got an answer wrong, the teacher had to punish the learner by administering an electric shock. The brilliance of the experiment is that the teacher is sitting in front of a shock box with 30 switches. The first switch is only 15 volts.
他們必須記住的物品清單。然後他們會把這份清單背給一個被要求扮演老師角色的志願者聽。主持研究的人告訴老師，每次學習者答錯時，老師必須透過給予電擊來懲罰學習者。這個實驗的絕妙之處在於，老師坐在一個有30個開關的電擊箱前面。第一個開關只有15伏特。
When you press a button, the learner who's in another room experiences some minimal level of shock. And then, of these 30 switches, the increment is 15 volts, 15, 30, 45, etc. And the person doesn't respond till it gets up to nearly a hundred. But the problem is that you are now in a slippery slope down. So each increment is not noticeable from the previous. And so now when you hit a hundred and the guy starts to say,
當你按下按鈕時，在另一個房間裡的學習者會經歷某種最低程度的電擊。然後，在這30個開關中，增量是15伏特，15、30、45等。直到電壓升到近一百時，那個人才會有反應。但問題是，你現在正處於向下傾斜的滑坡上。因此，每一個增量與前一個相比並不明顯。所以現在當你達到一百，那傢伙開始說，
hey, that really hurts, you're only slightly different from where you were. And so now when you hit 100 and the guy starts to say, hey, that really hurts, you're only slightly different from where you were. And at some point, you realize you should have stopped soon. We talked about this experiment at length in an episode of Hidden Brain titled, The Influence You Have. No one was actually being shocked in the experiment. The learner was actually an actor
嘿，這真的很痛，你的處境與之前相比只有微小的差異。所以現在當你達到100，那傢伙開始說，嘿，這真的很痛，你的處境與之前相比只有微小的差異。在某個時刻，你意識到你早就該停下來了。我們在名為《你所擁有的影響力》的《隱性大腦》單集中詳細討論了這個實驗。實驗中沒有人真正受到電擊。學習者實際上是與斯坦利·米爾格拉姆
working with Stanley Milgram. But the experiment unsettled people. That's because large numbers of volunteers who were playing the role of the teacher seemed perfectly willing to administer electric shocks that were ostensibly lethal enough to kill the learner. When the psychologists later debriefed some of the volunteers, they explained why they had followed orders. Why didn't you stop anyway? I did stop, but he kept going, keep going. Well, why didn't you just disregard what he said? He says it's got to go on, the experiment.
合作的演員。但這個實驗讓人們感到不安。那是因為扮演老師角色的大量志願者似乎完全願意實施電擊，而這些電擊表面上足以致命。心理學家後來對一些志願者進行了賽後訪談，他們解釋了為什麼會服從命令。你為什麼不乾脆停下來？我確實停下來了，但他一直叫我繼續，繼續。好吧，你為什麼不直接不理會他說的話？他說實驗必須進行下去。
Stanley Milgram's obedient studies made him famous well beyond the bounds of psychology classrooms and academic conferences. Across the country at Stanford, Philip Zimbardo was also developing the idea for a psychology experiment. It would be so audacious, so controversial, that it would generate even more shockwaves than the work of his former classmate.
斯坦利·米爾格拉姆的服從研究讓他在心理學課堂和學術會議之外名聲大噪。在全國另一端的斯坦福大學，菲利普·津巴多也在構思一個心理學實驗的想法。這個實驗將會如此的大膽、如此的具爭議性，以至於它將引發比他前同學的工作更大的震撼。
Coming up, how Philip Zimbardo came to create the infamous Stanford Prison Experiment. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. May it result in the punishment of the... Result in? Punishment... Higher note. Again. Again. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It was the summer of 1971. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
接下來，菲利普·津巴多是如何創造惡名昭著的斯坦福監獄實驗的。你正在收聽的是《隱性大腦》。我是香卡·維丹坦。願它帶來對……的懲罰？帶來？懲罰……音調高一點。再來。再來。這是《隱性大腦》。我是香卡·維丹坦。那是1971年的夏天。這是《隱性大腦》。我是香卡·維丹坦。
It was the summer of 1971. The Vietnam War was grinding on, as were increasingly large protests against it. The New York Times had begun publishing excerpts from the Pentagon Papers. The cult leader Charles Manson was behind bars, recently convicted of first degree murder and conspiracy to commit murder. It was a time of disruption and unrest. A time when Americans were feeling uneasy about their leaders and their nation's role in the world. Many young people in particular had the sense that the United States had gone astray and lost its moral compass. and lost its moral compass. It was against this backdrop that Philip Zimbardo put an ad in newspapers in Palo Alto, California. He was looking for male college students to volunteer for a study.
那是1971年的夏天。越南戰爭正在苦苦持續，反戰抗議活動也日益規模浩大。《紐約時報》開始發表《五角大廈文件》的摘錄。邪教頭子查爾斯·曼森身陷囹圄，最近剛被判處一級謀殺罪和謀殺陰謀罪。那是一個動盪不安的時代。一個美國人對他們的領導人以及國家在世界上的角色感到不安的時代。許多特別是年輕人，有一種美國已經誤入歧途、失去了道德指南針的感覺。
It was designed to understand how the roles we play shape how we behave. Who we are is really shaped not so much by somebody telling you what to do and not to do. It's really that we play roles. We're a student, we're a teacher, we're a worker, and those roles are always in some setting. And within those you belong to some subgroups, you know. Initially you're with the new workers, you're with the freshmen and so forth. And I said, so that's where we really want to study how power operates. He started to think about various scenarios where people play highly specific roles and
正是在這種背景下，菲利普·津巴多在加州帕洛阿爾托的報紙上登了一則廣告。他尋找男大學生志願者參與一項研究。它的設計目的是了解我們扮演的角色如何塑造我們的行為。我們是誰，其實很大程度上不是由別人告訴你該做什麼不該做什麼來塑造的。實際上是因為我們扮演角色。我們是學生，我們是老師，我們是工人，而這些角色總是在某個環境中。在這些環境中，你屬於某個子群體，你知道的。最初你和新工人在一起，你和大一新生在一起等等。我說，這就是我們真正想研究權力如何運作的地方。他開始思考人們扮演高度特定角色並
have varying degrees of power. I said, well, what kind of setting could we use to illustrate that? Now, you could have done a summer camp. In fact, since I did my experiment, many people have written to me and said, oh my God, I was in a summer camp where the counselors were brutal guards. But I thought prison because prisons are all about power. Prison. What Phil had in mind was not to study how prisons operate in a state like California, but something much more audacious.
擁有不同程度權力的各種情境。我說，好吧，我們可以用什麼樣的設定來闡明這一點？現在，你可以辦一個夏令營。事實上，自從我做了實驗以來，許多人寫信給我說，天哪，我曾在一個夏令營裡，那裡的輔導員是殘暴的警衛。但我想到的是監獄，因為監獄完全是關於權力的。監獄。菲爾腦海中想的不是研究加州這樣的州監獄如何運作，而是更為大膽的事情。
He wanted to build his own prison. In the basement of Stanford University's psychology department, Phil and his colleagues created prison cells, complete with bars, each designed to hold three people. A corridor served as the prison yard. A closet was set aside for prisoners who were to be confined to solitary confinement. For two weeks, Phil announced they would simulate a prison that would run 24 hours a day. Half the volunteers would play the role of prisoners, and half would play the role of prison guards. They sifted through about 75 applications they'd received from young men who were interested in the study.
他想建造自己的監獄。在斯坦福大學心理學系的地下室裡，菲爾和他的同事們建造了監獄牢房，配有鐵欄杆，每個牢房旨在容納三人。一條走廊充當了監獄的操場。一個壁櫥被劃出來作為關押需要被禁閉在單人牢房中的囚犯的地方。菲爾宣佈，他們將模擬一個全天候24小時運作的監獄，為期兩周。一半的志願者將扮演囚犯的角色，一半將扮演獄警的角色。他們篩選了從對這項研究感興趣的年輕人那裡收到的約75份申請。
It wasn't difficult to pick volunteers, except for one problem. No one wanted to play the role of a prison guard. It's 1971. These are anti-war activists. These are civil rights activists. There's a hip. Everybody's got hair down to here, not only long hair, and nobody wanted to be a guard. Guards are pigs. I didn't go to college to become a prison guard.
挑選志願者並不難，除了有一個問題。沒有人想扮演獄警的角色。那是1971年。這些都是反戰活動人士。這些都是民權活動人士。這是一種嬉皮士。每個人的頭髮都長到這裡，不僅頭髮很長，而且沒人想當警衛。警衛是豬。我上大學可不是為了當獄警。
Phil says the research team ended up flipping a coin to determine who would be guards and who would be prisoners. The day before the experiment began, he gathered the volunteers who had been chosen as guards for an orientation. Phil had decided that he himself would play the role of prison superintendent. An undergraduate research assistant would be the warden. Phil told the guards that they weren't allowed to physically harm the prisoners, but they were given broad latitude to maintain order. We want them to own the prison, okay, and so what it means is we
菲爾說，研究團隊最後透過擲硬幣來決定誰當警衛，誰當囚犯。實驗開始的前一天，他把被選為警衛的志願者們聚集起來進行了一場迎新。菲爾決定由他自己扮演監獄長的角色。一名大學生研究助理將擔任副獄長。菲爾告訴警衛，他們不被允許對囚犯進行身體傷害，但他們被賦予了維持秩序的廣泛自由裁量權。我們希望他們擁有這座監獄，好吧，這意味著我們
go with them to buy uniforms at army and navy stores. They have military kind of uniform. We give them symbols of power, handcuffs, billy clubs, whistles. And then I imposed an interesting subtle piece from the movie Cool Hand Luke, namely everybody when they were in contact with the prisoners had to wear silver reflecting sunglasses, which means that nobody can see your eyes. I want to stop here for a moment to note how unusual all of this was and how unthinkable it would be to run an experiment like this today. Phil did not have a host of administrators looking over his shoulder, making sure he didn't cross the line.
和他們一起去陸海军用品店買制服。他們穿著軍事風格的制服。我們賦予他們權力的象徵，手銬、警棍、口哨。然後我從電影《鐵窗喋血》中借鑒了一個有趣而微妙的橋樑，即每當他們與囚犯接觸時，都必須佩戴銀色反光太陽鏡，這意味著沒人能看到你的眼睛。我想在這裡停頓一下，注意到這一切是多麼的不尋常，以及今天進行這樣一項實驗是多麼不可想像。菲爾沒有一群行政人員在旁邊監督他，確保他沒有越界。
From a scientific standpoint, he was simultaneously playing both researcher and participant. He was the prison superintendent and also the person who was supposed to be dispassionately studying how the prison operated. The theatricality of the experiment was no accident. Phil was an impresario and he loved being the center of attention. One student who took an introductory psychology class at Stanford in the 1970s told me that Phil showed up on the first day wearing a long black cape.
從科學的角度來看，他同時扮演了研究者和參與者的雙重角色。他是監獄長，同時也是那個應該冷靜客觀地研究監獄運作方式的人。實驗的戲劇性並非偶然。菲爾是一位藝術經紀人，他喜歡成為注目的焦點。一位在1970年代修過斯坦福大學心理學入門課程的學生告訴我，菲爾第一天出現時穿著一件長黑披風。
The professor stood before the slack-jawed students, swept his cape 360 degrees around him like a magician, and intoned, welcome to psychology. Others remembered Phil would wear that cloak on his travels, including when he went through airports. With his piercing eyes and flamboyant style, I bet he looked every part the wizard. To make the drama really pop for his prison experiment,
這位教授站在目瞪口呆的學生面前，像個魔術師一樣將披風在他周圍旋轉了360度，並莊嚴地吟誦道：歡迎來到心理學。其他人則記得菲爾在旅行時會穿著那件披風，包括他穿過機場的時候。憑藉他銳利的眼神和華麗的風格，我敢打賭他看起來完全就是個巫師。為了讓他的監獄實驗充滿戲劇效果，
Phil even involved the Palo Alto Police Department. Again, zero chance this happens today. I recruited the Palo Alto police department, the real police department, to make simulated arrests, to go to each kid's place, ask for the name of the kid, and then give them their Miranda rights. You have a right to remain silent, a right for a lawyer.
菲爾甚至讓帕洛阿爾托警察局參與進來。再說一次，這在今天發生的機率為零。我招募了帕洛阿爾托警察局，真正的警察局，來進行模擬逮捕，去每個孩子的住處，詢問孩子的名字，然後宣讀他們的米蘭達權利。你有權保持沉默，有權聘請律師。
And then bring them down to where the squad cars with the lights flashing, lean them against the car, handcuff them, give them the rights again, and again, neighbors and everybody's looking around. The police then took the students to the real police station to be fingerprinted and have their mug shots taken. They then put a blindfold on them
然後把他們帶到警燈閃爍的巡邏車停放的地方，讓他們靠在車上，戴上手槍，再次宣讀權利，周圍的鄰居和其他所有人都圍觀著。警察隨後將學生帶到真正的警察局去按指紋並拍存檔照片。然後他們給他們戴上眼罩，
and had them wait in a cell. If all of this wasn't bad enough, what happened next was truly shocking. Then my graduate students came, took the prisoner, put him in their car, took him down to our prison and they stripped him naked and when they take off the blindfold the kid is standing naked and all the guards are around laughing, mocking him, and say, welcome to the Sanford jail. The prisoners were given smocks and flip-flops. They were each assigned numbers that were sewn onto their clothing.
讓他們在牢房裡等候。如果所有這些還不夠糟糕，接下來發生的事情簡然令人震驚。然後我的研究生來了，把囚犯帶走，放到他們的車裡，帶到我們的監獄，然後把他脫個精光，當他們摘下眼罩時，那個孩子光著身子站在那裡，所有的警衛都圍在周圍嘲笑他、嘲弄他，說：歡迎來到斯坦福監獄。囚犯們被發給了罩衫和夾腳拖鞋。他們的衣服上都縫上了各自分配的編號。
And they all had an iron chain and a lock on one ankle. That was there all the time. And instead of cutting their hair, they wore women's nylon stocking caps. So it was really de-individuation, dehumanization. By the end of the first day, the experiment wasn't going as Phil thought it would. He briefly considered shutting it down, not because he had qualms about what he had put his volunteers through, but because the young men playing the role of guards refused to
他們每人的腳踝上都有一個鐵鍊和一把鎖。那東西一直都在。而且他們沒有剪頭髮，而是戴著女式尼龍絲襪帽。所以這真的是去個體化、去人性化。到了第一天結束時，實驗的進展並不像菲爾想像的那樣。他短暫地考慮過關閉它，不是因為他對自己讓志願者經歷的事情感到良心不安，而是因為扮演警衛的年輕人拒絕
embrace their roles. The kids playing the role of guards just felt awkward. In fact, you can hear we videotaped a lot of it. And they'd say, come on, you guys, stop laughing. This is serious business. But then they could take it seriously. Everyone feels fine. So let's hear everyone say, Mr. Correctional Officer, I feel fine.
接受他們的角色。扮演警衛角色的孩子們感到很不自在。事實上，你可以聽到——我們錄下了很多畫面。他們會說：拜託，夥計們，別笑了。這是嚴肅的事情。但隨後他們就能認真對待了。每個人都感覺很好。所以讓我們聽每個人都說：矯正官先生，我感覺很好。
Mr. Correctional Officer, I feel fine. Mr. Correctional Officer, I feel fine. Phil decided to keep the experiment going. Early in the morning on day two, the prisoners realized that the young men playing the role of guards were not the only ones who were playing the role of guards. They were the only ones who were playing the role of guards. They were the only ones who were playing the role of guards. They were the only ones who were playing the role of guards. They were the only ones who were playing the role of guards. They were the only ones who were playing the role of guards. They were the onlyal Officer, I feel fine. Phil decided to keep the experiment going.
矯正官先生，我感覺很好。矯正官先生，我感覺很好。菲爾決定讓實驗繼續下去。第二天清晨，囚犯們在被警衛吹口哨和命令他們出牢房接受盤問吵醒後發動了暴動。快點！快點！走！走！出去！快點！
Early in the morning on day two, the prisoners revolted after being woken by guards blasting whistles and ordering them out of their cells for drugs. Come on! Come on! Go! Go! Out! Come on!
出去！他們扯掉絲襪帽，扯掉身上的編號，把自己反鎖在牢房裡，然後犯了一個巨大的錯誤。他們扯掉絲襪帽，扯掉編號，把自己反鎖在牢房裡，然後犯了一個巨大的錯誤。他們開始嘲笑警衛。像你這個小混混，等我出去我要踢你的屁股。突然警衛來找我說我們該怎麼辦？我說這是你們的監獄，你們想怎麼辦？
Out! They ripped off their stocking caps, they ripped off their numbers, they barricaded themselves in their cell, and then they made a huge mistake. They ripped off the stocking caps, they ripped off the numbers, they barricaded themselves in their cell and then they made a huge mistake. They started ridiculing the guards. Like you little punk when I get out I'm going to kick your butt. And suddenly the guards come to me and say what are we going to do? I said it's your prison, what do you want to do?
他們說我們需要增援。這意味著早班有三個警衛。他們召集了所有其他警衛。警衛們開會，開了一個會，說，好吧，我們必須以暴制暴。所以他們撞開房門，把囚犯拖出來，把他們全部脫光衣服。他們將叛亂的帶頭人關進單人牢房。突然他們說，這些是危險的囚犯。這些是危險的囚犯。這些是危險的囚犯。
They said we need reinforcements. So it means there are three guards on the morning shift. They call in all the other guards. The guards meet, they have a meeting, say, okay, we've got to treat force with force. So they break down the doors, they drag the prisoners out, they strip them all naked. They put the ringleaders of rebellion in solitary confinement. Suddenly they say, these are dangerous prisoners. These are dangerous prisoners. These are dangerous prisoners.
這就是轉變。他們不再是像你這樣的大學生。每都知道他們是大學生。所以現在他們是危險的囚犯。你怎麼對待危險的囚犯？你必須教導他們，他們沒有權力。他們擁有負權力，因為叛亂的可能性一直存在。這對真實監獄裡的
That's the switch. They're no longer college students like you. And everybody knows they're college students. So now they are dangerous prisoners. And what do you do with dangerous prisoners? You have to teach them that they have no power. They have minus power, because the potential for rebellion is always there. And this is true of real guards in
真實警衛來說也是如此。你如何向囚犯傳達你掌握了所有的權力而他們一無所有？所以在方方面面、每一天，你都必須壓制他們的自由，壓制他們叛亂的可能性。你必須證明，主要是透過做一些隨意、愚蠢的事情，證明你擁有權力。所以你講個笑話他們笑了，你懲罰他們。他們講個笑話他們沒笑，你懲罰他們。所以你創造了一個完全隨意的環境，囚犯——大學生——根本不知道該做什麼。
real prisons. How do you convey to prisoners that you hold all the power and they hold none? So in every way and every day, you have to suppress their freedom, suppress their likelihood to rebel. And you had to demonstrate, mostly by doing arbitrary, stupid things, that you had power. So you tell a joke and they laugh, you punish them. They tell a joke and they don't laugh, you punish them. So you create a totally arbitrary environment where they have, with prisoners, college students, have no idea what to do.
多年後，菲爾被請去協助理解伊拉克阿布格萊布監獄美軍警衛的行為。年輕的美國軍人虐待性地羞辱伊拉克囚犯，並假裝要電擊他們。他們剝光囚犯的衣服，用咆哮的狗威脅他們，並在囚犯驚恐尖叫時大笑拍照。在斯坦福監獄，一些囚犯被剝奪了上廁所的休息時間，被迫用桶子當馬桶。
Years later, Phil would be called in to help understand the behavior of U.S. guards at the Abu Ghraib prison in Iraq. Young American service members sadistically humiliated Iraqi prisoners and pretended they were going to electrocute them. They stripped prisoners naked, threatened them with snarling dogs, and laughed and took photos as prisoners screamed in terror. At the Stanford prison, some prisoners were denied bathroom breaks and were forced to use buckets as toilets.
然後懲罰通常只是俯臥撐、開合跳，但隨後它升級了，正如我們在阿布格萊布看到的那樣，它總是向著性暗示的方向升級。所以警衛說，你是弗蘭肯斯坦，你是弗蘭肯斯坦夫人，像弗蘭肯斯坦那樣走路，好吧，然後擁抱他們，說我愛你。並說你愛2093。我愛你。然後一些小事情，或者，你知道的，你們這些女駱駝，你們這些男駱駝彎下腰，現在，你知道的，去騎上去，
And then punishment is usually just push-ups, jumping jacks, but then it escalates and it always escalates as we saw in Albert Grave, toward the sexual. So the guards say, you're Frankenstein, you're Mrs. Frankenstein, walk like Frankenstein, okay, and hug them, say I love you. And say that you love 2093. I love you. And then little things like this, or, you know, your female camels, your male camels bend over, now, you know, hump them,
所以這是個雙關語。這是在大學生的實驗中模擬雞姦。現在其中有些我沒有看到，因為實驗是24小時進行的，而且最糟糕的事情大多發生在夜間。警衛將他們的俘虜分成了好囚犯和壞囚犯，那些順從的和那些反叛的。囚犯必須向警衛報告所有違規行為。囚犯必須向警衛報告所有違規行為。
so it's a play on words. And it's simulating sodomy and an experiment with college students. Now some of this I didn't see because the experiments going on 24 hours a day, and most of the things that the worst things happen at night. The guards separated their captives into good prisoners and bad prisoners, those who were compliant and those who rebelled. Prisoners must report all rule violations to the guards. Prisoners must report all rule violations to the guards.
再來。囚犯必須向警衛報告所有違規行為。不遵守上述任何規定可能會導致懲罰。不遵守任何
Again. Prisoners must report all rule violations to the guards. Failure to obey any of the above rules may result in punishment. Failure to obey any from the experiment and were allowed to leave. On the third day of the experiment, those who remained were allowed short visits from parents and friends. Two days later, in the evening, another visitor came to the jail, a graduate student named
退出實驗並被允許離開。在實驗的第三天，留下來的人被允許接受父母和朋友的短暫探視。兩天後的傍晚，另一位訪客來到了監獄，那是一位名叫
Christina Maslack. She was also Phil's girlfriend. What she saw appalled her. She sees something which from her point of view is unimaginable that should happen anywhere. Unimaginable should happen in an experiment, namely guards are cursing and screaming and pushing prisoners. Prisoners have bags over their head, they're shuffling their legs. Their legs are chains, like a chain gang.
克里斯蒂娜·馬斯拉克的graduate student（研究生）。她也是菲爾的女朋友。她所看到的景象令她大驚失色。她看到了在她看來在任何地方都不應該發生的、難以想像的事情。在實驗中竟然會發生難以想像的事，也就是警衛在咒罵、尖叫和推搡囚犯。囚犯頭上套著袋子，拖著雙腿走路。他們的腳上戴著鐵鍊，就像勞改隊一樣。
It's like, you know, like you see in pictures of the South, you know, in Louisiana prisons. And I'm looking at this and literally I have eight o'clock breakfast, you know, ten o'clock parole board hearing, twelve o'clock, and it's ten o'clock and it simply says, toilet run. What Christina saw as a dehumanizing abuse of power, Phil, in his role as prison superintendent, saw as a toilet run. In other words, it was simply time to check off an item on his bureaucratic to-do list. I look up and I put a check mark.
這就像，你知道的，就像你在南方照片中看到的那樣，路易斯安那州的監獄。我正看著這個，字面上我有八點鐘的早餐，你知道的，十點鐘的假釋委員會聽證會，十二點鐘，現在是十點鐘，上面簡單地寫著：上廁所。克里斯蒂娜眼中去人性化的權力濫用，在菲爾作為監獄長的眼裡，只不過是一次廁所放風。換句話說，這僅僅是勾掉他官僚主義待辦清單上的一項任務。我抬起頭打了一個勾。
So what I'm seeing is nothing more than an administrative check mark. So I am now in the mentality of a prison superintendent, which is the mentality of an administrator. And she's looking at this as a person with feelings. She had been a student, she's about to be a professor, and she sees this as horrific. No, no, no, no, no! No, no, no, no! No, no, no, no! Christina started to cry and fled outside, with Phil at her heels.
所以我看到的只是一個行政上的勾號。所以我現在進入的是監獄長的心理狀態，也就是行政人員的心理狀態。而她是以一個有感情的人的身份在看這件事。她曾是一名學生，即將成為一名教授，她認為這太可怕了。不，不，不，不，不！不，不，不，不，不！不，不，不，不，不！克里斯蒂娜開始哭泣並逃到外面，菲爾緊隨其後。
And now we're standing outside in the fresh air, it's now 11 o'clock at night, or 10.30 at night, in front of the psychology building. And she's saying, how could you see what I see and not get upset? And I'm saying, what do you see? It's the dynamics of human nature. It's the power of the situation.
現在我們站在外面的新鮮空氣中，當時是晚上11點，或是晚上10點半，在心理學大樓前。她說，你怎麼能看到我看到的卻不感到心煩意亂？我說，你看到了什麼？這是人性的動態。這是情境的力量。
I'm giving all the psychological jargon and she's giving me the humanity of the situation. Boys are suffering. They're not prisoners. That's what she's saying. They're not prisoners in our guards. They're boys and you're responsible. How could you allow this to happen? They stood there in the California night and a gulf grew between them. She says, I don't understand. I know you from other situations. You're a caring, loving professor. You love students. Students love you. How could you see this?
我說著所有的心理學術語，而她則在向我講述情境中的人性。男孩們在受苦。他們不是囚犯。這就是她所說的。他們不是我們警衛的囚犯。他們是男孩，而你要負責任。你怎麼能允許這種事發生？他們站在加州的夜色中，兩人之間的鴻溝越來越大。她說，我不理解。我從其他情況下認識你。你是一個富有同情心、有愛心的教授。你愛學生。學生愛你。你怎麼能看到這一幕？
There's this chasm between us. I'm over here and you're over here and we're looking at the same thing and we see two totally different worlds. And then she says, I'm not sure I want to continue my relationship with you if this is the real you. I thought you were someone else when I started dating you and I don't know who this is. So that's the ultimate power of a situation to transform. She's looking at me and she knew me for a number of years
我們之間存在著一條鴻溝。我在這裡，你在這裡，我們看著同一件事，卻看到了兩個完全不同的世界。然後她說，如果這就是真實的你，我不知道我是否想繼續與你的關係。我開始跟你約會時以為你是另一個人，而我不知道這是誰。這就是情境轉化人的終極力量。她看著我，她認識我好多年了，
as a professor there, and she's looking at me and saying, I don't know who you are. And really what she's saying, do you know who you are? And the answer is no, that this is, what I had become is abhorrent. I mean, I fight authoritarianism. I fight, you know, I'm as liberal as most people get. I'm anti-authoritarian, anti-control, anti-structure, all these things.
作為那裡的教授，她看著我說，我不知道你是誰。而她真正想說的是，你知道你是誰嗎？答案是不知道，這——我所變成的是令人厭惡的。我的意思是，我反對威權主義。我反對，你知道的，我和大多數人一樣自由派。我反對威權、反對控制、反對結構，所有這些事情。
And that's what I became. I mean, I became my worst inner enemy. And at that point, I just stopped. I mean, I think it's when she said, I'm not sure I want to continue my relationship. It was like a double slap in the face. I said, oh, my God, what's happened to me? It was really like she should have just shook me and said,
而這正是我所成為的。我的意思是，我變成了我內心最糟糕的敵人。就在那時，我停了下來。我的意思是，我想當她說，我不知道我是否想繼續這段關係時。那就像雙重耳光打在臉上。我說，哦，天哪，我怎麼了。真的就像她應該狠狠搖醒我然後說：
wake up, the dream is over, the game is over. In a theatrical irony even he could not have devised, Phil had demonstrated in his own behavior what he hoped his experiment would demonstrate to others. He had become so caught up in the roles he was playing, the swashbuckling scientist, the prison superintendent, the high wizard of psychology, that he had lost track of his own values.
醒醒吧，夢醒了，遊戲結束了。帶著一種連他自己都設計不出來的戲劇性諷刺，菲爾用他自己的行為證明了他希望他的實驗能向其他人證明的事情。他太過投入自己扮演的角色——游俠科學家、監獄長、心理學高級巫師——以至於他迷失了自己的價值觀。
Six days after it started, the Stanford Prison Experiment was over. But before the volunteers could leave, Phil interviewed them. Then we had all the prisoners come together to debrief. We spent hours, then all the guards separately, and then the prisoners and guards. Because I use that as a moral re-education, because I could say we all did bad things, including me. What do we learn from this?
斯坦福监狱实验在开始六天后就结束了。但在志愿者离开之前，菲尔对他们进行了访谈。然后我们让所有囚犯集合起来进行复盘。我们花了几个小时，然后是所有看守分别复盘，最后是囚犯和看守一起。因为我把这当作一堂道德再教育课，因为我可以宣称我们都做过坏事，包括我在内。我们从中学到了什么？
We learn about the power of the situation. We learn to be aware of how easy each of us, he gets seduced into a role. He followed up again weeks later with the volunteers and asked the prisoners if they thought they would have behaved like the guards if the roles had been reversed. They said, I don't know, I probably would have played by the rules, but I would not have been as creative. That the worst guards were the ones who clearly went beyond the rules.
我们了解到了情境的力量。我们学会去意识到，我们每个人是多么容易被诱导并陷入某个角色中。几周后，他又对志愿者进行了回访，询问囚犯们如果角色互换，他们是否觉得自己会像看守那样行事。他们回答说，我不知道，我可能也会按规矩办事，但我不会那么有创意。最糟糕的看守显然是那些超越了规则的人。
That is, it was clear what you had to do to be a guard. And it was going beyond you had to do to be a guard and it was going beyond the boundary of your role. That in every role there is a moral latitude and clearly some guards went beyond it. You know, you could say do 10 push-ups, do 10 more, but then they tell somebody to sit on your back when you're doing push-ups, that's going beyond the thing. You know, to tell somebody to kiss the other guy as the bride of Frankenstein, that's being creatively evil. So again, most of the prisoners said, I'm not sure what I would do, but I would be a guard who played by the rules,
也就是说，要当好一个看守，你必须做什么是一目了然的。而那些超越了你作为看守本该做的事，甚至越过了你角色界限的行为则是另一回事。在每个角色中都有一个道德容忍度，显然有些看守超越了这个界限。你知道，你可以说做10个俯卧撑，再做10个，但接着他们让别人坐在你做俯卧撑的背上，这就过头了。你知道的，让一个人去亲吻另一个人作为弗兰肯斯坦的新娘，那就是富有创造性的邪恶。所以再次说明，大多数囚犯都表示，我不确定自己会怎么做，但我会是一个遵守规则的看守，
and not develop new rules. Phil's study sparked intense public interest and criticism, both of which have continued to this day. For starters, there was the inhumane treatment of the volunteers playing the role of prisoners, the decision to strip them naked, the physical punishments and verbal abuse, the restricted access to toilet facilities. Both the Stanford Prison Experiment and Stanley Milgram's Obedience Studies prompted universities to create more rigorous review processes before green-lighting experiments. I think it's impossible any review board at any major university today
而不是发明新规则。菲尔的研究引发了公众极大的兴趣和批评，这两种反响一直持续到今天。首先，是对扮演囚犯的志愿者进行的不人道对待，剥光他们衣服的决定、身体惩罚和言语虐待、限制使用卫生设施。斯坦福监狱实验和斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的服从实验都促使大学在批准实验之前建立更严格的审查程序。我认为今天任何一所主要大学的审查委员会都不可能
would green-light a study like the Stanford Prison Experiment. In addition to the ethical concerns, scholars have also criticized the experiment as bad science or not really science at all. Some have argued that the guards were essentially primed to be abusive. As Phil noted earlier, the guards were given to understand the prison was theirs and that they should do what was needed to maintain order. They were arguably being nudged to amp up their behavior to please the researchers. Remember how Phil almost shut the experiment down the first day because nothing much was happening? The guards may well have picked up on that, a possibility confirmed recently by volunteer Dave Eshelman who played a guard known for being particularly aggressive to the prisoners. He was interviewed for a documentary
批准像斯坦福监狱实验这样的研究。除了伦理方面的担忧，学者们还批评该实验是一项糟糕的科学，或者根本算不上科学。一些人认为，看守们本质上是被灌输了虐待倾向。正如菲尔早些时候所指出的那样，看守们被告知监狱是他们的，他们应该采取必要措施来维持秩序。可以说，他们是在被潜移默化地推动着升级自己的行为，以取悦研究人员。还记得菲尔在第一天差点因为没发生什么大事而叫停实验吗？看守们很可能注意到了这一点，最近参与实验、扮演以对囚犯特别具有攻击性而闻名的看守戴夫·埃舍尔曼证实了这种可能性。他接受了一部纪录片的采访，
film titled, The Stanford Prison Experiment, Unlocking the Truth. Dave says he thought the experiment was designed to show that prisons were terrible. He believed his role was to provide proof. Proof that prisons are an evil environment. Given the times and given the fact we were students and very anti-establishment, we would have done anything to prove that this prison system was an evil institution. We were happy to play that role. For his part, Phil Zimbardo continued to defend
这部纪录片名为《斯坦福监狱实验：揭开真相》。戴夫说他当时认为这个实验的设计就是为了证明监狱是可怕的。他相信自己的任务就是提供证据。证明监狱是一个邪恶的环境。鉴于当时的时代背景，以及我们当时都是学生且极具反叛精神，为了证明这个监狱系统是一个邪恶的机构，我们愿意做任何事。我们很乐意扮演那个角色。就菲尔·津巴多本人而言，他在余下的漫长职业生涯中一直在为
the Stanford Prison Experiment for the rest of his very long career. He felt the question he was trying to answer was a vital one, and the best way to do so was to see how people responded to a situation in the real world, in real time, rather than creating an abstract scenario in which they imagined how they might respond. All of that research, in a way, really is trying to answer the question from childhood, what makes good people do bad things? My focus has always been on trying to understand how situations shape us, mold us, and corrupt
斯坦福监狱实验进行辩护。他觉得他试图回答的问题至关重要，而最好的方法就是观察人们在现实世界、实时情境中对事件的反应，而不是创造一个让他们想象自己会如何反应的抽象场景。从某种程度上说，所有这些研究真的都在试图回答那个从童年起就有的问题：是什么让好人做出坏事？我的重点一直放在试图理解情境是如何塑造我们、雕琢我们并腐蚀我们的。
us. Starting with an evil orientation, what I try to do is create evil. It's really studying evil from the inside out. Theologians, poets, dramatists, sociologists, you know, criminologists have studied evil, but they've studied evil in place. So what I try to do that's unique is create it. You see the process of transformation.
从一个邪恶的基调开始，我试图做的是创造邪恶。这实际上是从内向外研究邪恶。神学家、诗人、戏剧家、社会学家，你知道的，犯罪学家都研究过邪恶，但他们研究的都是既成的邪恶。所以我试图做的独特之处在于创造它。你能看到转变的过程。
You see people who start off on day one, normal, healthy. You put them in role and then you see the divergence. The role becomes the person. And you play a character and then it becomes your identity. Over the years, Phil went on to work on other topics. For a time, he was president of the American Psychological Association. Around 2010, I remember attending a talk he gave
你能看到人们在第一天开始时是正常而健康的。你把他们放入角色中，然后你就能看到分歧。角色成了这个人。你扮演一个角色，然后它就成了你的身份。多年来，菲尔继续致力于其他主题的研究。有一段时间，他是美国心理学协会的主席。大约在2010年，我记得我听过他的一次演讲，
at a psychology conference. The line of young scholars who waited to shake his hand afterwards stretched the length of a very long ballroom. Phil Zimbardo died in October 2024. He was 91 years old. When we come back, the larger lessons of the Stanford Prison Experiment. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
那是在一个心理学会议上。会后排着长队等待与他握手的年轻学者们排满了整个长长的宴会厅。菲尔·津巴多于2024年10月去世，享年91岁。稍后回来，我们将探讨斯坦福监狱实验更深层次的教训。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 2004, after the horrific abuses at Iraq's Abu Ghraib prison came to light, American leaders like President George W. Bush, Vice President Dick Cheney, Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld, and the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff Richard Myers said that the servicemen and women who had perpetrated the abuses were just bad apples.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。2004年，伊拉克阿布格莱布监狱骇人听闻的虐囚丑闻曝光后，美国领导人如乔治·W·布什总统、副总统迪克·切尼、国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德以及参谋长联席会议主席理查德·迈尔斯声称，实施虐待的军人只是害群之马。
The lawyer for one of the servicemen got in touch with Phil Zimbardo. I became an expert witness for one of the guards, Chip Frederick, because I knew that these were good apples that somebody put in a bad barrel. That's the metaphor I started using. In fact, I know I gave an interview at NPR,
其中一名军人的律师联系了菲尔·津巴多。我成为了其中一名看守奇普·弗雷德里克的专家证人，因为我知道这些都是好苹果，只是被别人放进了一个坏木桶里。这就是我开始使用的隐喻。事实上，我知道我在NPR接受过一次采访，
and I was the first to say, I want to believe our American soldiers are good. They're not bad apples, as Cheney and Rumsfeld and Bush and General Myers say. I believe they were good apples when they got there and somebody put him in a very bad barrel and that barrel looks exactly like the prison study. So I got to know really everything there is to know about Albuquerque. The more Phil read about the abuses in the prison, the greater the parallels he saw with the Stanford prison experiment. It told him, notwithstanding all his errors and misjudgments, the study had
我是第一个说“我愿意相信我们的美国士兵是好人。他们不是切尼、拉姆斯菲尔德、布什和迈尔斯将军所说的害群之马”的人。我相信他们到达那里时是好苹果，有人把他们放进了一个非常糟糕的木桶里，而那个木桶看起来和那个监狱研究一模一样。所以我几乎了解了关于阿尔伯克基的一切。菲尔对监狱虐待事件了解得越多，他看到的与斯坦福监狱实验的相似之处就越多。这告诉他，尽管存在种种错误和误判，这项研究确实
been on to something really important. The only abuses happened in that prison on the night shift. None happened on the day shift. And it turns out in Abu Ghraib, part of the unit was the center of interrogation. So you have military intelligence with its set of interrogators interrogating. Now, they're not getting any information. For the military, it's called actionable intelligence because what happened was when the insurgency broke out, the military was caught blind.
触及了非常重要的事情。虐待事件只发生在那座监狱的夜班。白班没有发生。事实证明，在阿布格莱布，一部分部队是审讯中心。所以你有军事情报部门带着他们的一组审讯人员在进行审讯。现在，他们没有得到任何信息。对于军方来说，这被称为可操作的情报，因为发生的情况是，当叛乱爆发时，军方被打了个措手不及。
They had no idea this was going to happen. So they started arresting all men and boys around explosion. So they had no information, but now they're interrogating them and they're getting nothing. So military intelligence goes ahead of military police and says, we need your guys to help us. They've got to prepare the prisoners for interrogation, break them, take the gloves off, all these euphemisms.
他们根本不知道会发生这种事。于是他们开始逮捕爆炸地点周围所有的成年男子和男孩。所以他们没有情报，但现在他们在审讯这些人，却什么也审不出来。于是军事情报部门走到宪兵前面说，我们需要你们的人来帮我们。他们必须为审讯做好囚犯的准备，击溃他们的意志，撕破脸皮，所有这些委婉的说法。
And so when we interrogate them, they're going to spill the beans. Much like in the Stanford Prison Experiment, the young guards in Abu Ghraib received the message that their prisoners needed to be humiliated and brought to heel. At Stanford, those messages implicitly came from Phil himself. In Iraq, they came from senior officers and in the name of national security and patriotism. And then in three months, no senior officer ever goes down to a dungeon to see what's happening. So this gives them complete liberty to reproduce the Sanford Prison Study in spades, namely
这样当我们审讯他们时，他们就会吐露实情。就像在斯坦福监狱实验中一样，阿布格莱布的年轻看守们接收到的信息是，他们的囚犯需要被羞辱并被驯服。在斯坦福，这些信息隐晦地来自菲尔本人。在伊拉克，它们来自高级军官，并打着国家安全和爱国主义的旗号。然后在这三个月里，没有任何高级军官去地牢看看发生了什么。这就给了他们完全的自由，将斯坦福监狱研究变本加厉地重演，也就是
to do whatever you want. The guards were not part of the interrogation team. They were simply humiliating, tormenting the prisoners to break their will. So this is the clearest situational variable. They give guards total power with no oversight recipe for abuse. And in fact, what they said was, every time an explosion goes off and one of your buddies dies, his blood is on your hands explicitly. So it's not like these guys were getting off on a torture. Essentially, you are part of our national security realm. And if you remember, you know, in the war, it was everybody is for us or against us.
为所欲为。看守们不属于审讯小组。他们只是在羞辱、折磨囚犯以摧毁他们的意志。所以这是最明显的情境变量。他们赋予看守绝对的权力却没有任何监督，这就是虐待的配方。事实上，他们说的是，每次发生爆炸，你的一个战友牺牲，他的血就直接沾在你的手上。所以这并不是说这些家伙是从酷刑中获得快感。本质上，你是我们国家安全领域的一部分。如果你还记得，你知道的，在那场战争中，每个人要么支持我们，要么反对我们。
So really, if you don't do this, you know, you're suspect. Once the sides were clearly drawn and marked, once the stakes of doing their jobs were laid out, Phil says the situation came to shape the behavior of Chip Frederick and the other young guards. So the guards got sucked in, but then as we said earlier, it's now the night shift. So the biggest contributor to evil is boredom. And so you're bored, you've got 12 hours to kill, and places filled with stress and danger. And the only playthings are prisoners. And most of the prisoners are already naked.
所以实际上，如果你不这么做，你知道的，你就是可疑的。一旦阵地界限分明，一旦他们工作的利害关系明确摆出，菲尔说，这种情境开始塑造奇普·弗雷德里克和其他年轻看守的行为。所以看守们被卷进去了，但正如我们之前所说，现在是夜班。因此，导致邪恶的最大因素是无聊。所以你觉得无聊，你有12个小时要打发，而这个地方充满了压力和危险。唯一的玩物就是囚犯。而且大多数囚犯已经赤身裸体了。
And it's never been the case we have female guards with naked prisoners. Again, for Muslims, you never show yourself naked in front of a woman. And so the sexual agenda is there. I mean, it's just boiling over. And it only goes down. It gets worse and worse and worse.
而且我们从来没有过女看守面对赤身裸体囚犯的情况。同样，对于穆斯林来说，你绝不能在女人面前赤身裸体。所以性别的议题在那里。我的意思是，它正在沸腾。而且情况只会急转直下。变得越来越糟。
So the images, the dozen images that were shown on television are almost the least subjectial. The others are even worse. When I interviewed Phil in April 2013, he told me he continued to be fascinated by the idea that ordinary people could turn into monsters. continued to be fascinated by the idea that ordinary people could turn into monsters. He had published a book called The Lucifer Effect, understanding how good people turn evil. Sitting across from me at a studio at NPR, Phil cited the words of the historian and philosopher Hannah Arendt about the Nazi leader, Adolf Eichmann. Hannah Arendt, in trying to understand Eichmann, this brutal killer, coined the term the banality of evil,
所以这些图像，电视上播出的十几张图像几乎是最不具暗示性的。其他的甚至更糟。2013年4月，当我采访菲尔时，他告诉我，他仍然对“普通人可以变成怪物”这个想法着迷。他仍然对“普通人可以变成怪物”这个想法着迷。他曾出版过一本书叫《路西法效应：好人是如何变成恶魔的》。坐在NPR工作室我对面时，菲尔引用了历史学家兼哲学家汉娜·阿伦特关于纳粹头目阿道夫·艾希曼的话。汉娜·阿伦特在试图理解艾希曼这个残酷的杀手时，创造了“平庸之恶”这个词，
meaning this guy looks like your Uncle Charlie. I mean, her phrase is he was terrifyingly normal. Phil told me he had started to ask himself a new question. If circumstances and situations could turn people bad, couldn't different circumstances and situations turn people good? And I said, well, isn't that true? If we flip it, isn't there the banality of heroes? That most heroes are ordinary people, everyday people. They do little things each day that we never know about unless they live in a major media city and somebody has to make a videotape.
意思是这家伙看起来就像你的查理叔叔。我的意思是，她的话是“他可怕地正常”。菲尔告诉我，他开始问自己一个新问题。如果环境和情境能让人变坏，难道不同的环境和情境就不能让人变好吗？我说，难道不是吗？如果我们反过来，难道不存在“英雄的平庸”吗？大多数英雄都是普通人，日常生活中普普通通的人。他们每天做一些我们永远不会知道的小事，除非他们生活在一个大型媒体城市且有人拍了录像。
Then I started thinking of heroic things that I knew people did. And then I said, gee, now we should celebrate heroism more than we do. Well, the problem is with a lot of the stuff on heroes, it really made them seem extra special. These are male warriors, Agamemnon, Achilles, Samurai, you know, and the more I read, and there's almost no research on heroism. Phil started working in high schools, helping students understand the steps that lead people to betray their values
然后我开始思考我所知道的人们所做的英雄事迹。接着我说，天哪，现在我们应该比以往更多地颂扬英雄主义。嗯，问题在于，关于英雄的很多事迹，确实让他们显得格外特殊。这些都是男性勇士，阿伽门农、阿喀琉斯、武士，你知道的，我读得越多，就发现几乎没有什么关于英雄主义的研究。菲尔开始在高中工作，帮助学生理解导致人们背叛价值观的步骤，
and how they could stand up to injustice. We started developing classroom modules, which first started off by saying, be aware of the power of the dark side. So we teach you about the prison study, the messages of a Milgram study. We show videos of a woman lying on a subway station and Liverpool station in London. In five minutes, the little clock is going,
以及他们如何能够站出来反对不公正。我们开始开发课堂模块，最初的模块是教导：要意识到黑暗面的力量。所以我们向你介绍监狱研究、米格尔实验所传达的信息。我们播放了视频，一个女人躺在伦敦利物浦街地铁站。在五分钟里，小钟表在走，
35 people pass right by her and nobody stops. The question is, what's wrong? Are these bad people? So the kids say, we would help. Well, what's the difference between you sitting here and people there? And they come up with situational differences. And then we teach them these lessons, the bison effect, prejudice, discrimination.
35个人从她身边径直走过，没有人停下来。问题是，出什么毛病了？这些人是坏人吗？所以孩子们说，我们会帮忙的。那么，你坐在这里的人和那里的人有什么区别呢？他们想出了情境上的差异。然后我们教他们这些课，旁观者效应、偏见、歧视。
We get the college kids that teach high school kids, high school kids that teach middle school kids. It offsets all the evil I've done. It's been really enriching. In 1492, Christopher Columbus set sail from Spain in search of the great continent of Asia. He figured he needed to go west. Some of his misjudgment was based on erroneous maps and miscalculations about the size of the earth,
我们让大学生教高中生，高中生教初中生。这抵消了我做过的所有邪恶之事。这真的非常丰富。1492年，克里斯托弗·哥伦布从西班牙起航，寻找伟大的亚洲大陆。他认为自己需要向西走。他的一些误判是基于错误的地图和对地球大小的错误计算，
and some of it was simple overconfidence. Convinced he was on the right track, Christopher Columbus sailed across the Atlantic Ocean. When he landed in the Bahamas, he believed he had found Asia. He labeled the people of the region Indians. He kept going, believing he would soon stumble on China and Japan.
其中一部分则是单纯的过度自信。坚信自己走在正确轨道上的克里斯托弗·哥伦布横渡了大西洋。当他在巴哈马群岛登陆时，他相信自己已经找到了亚洲。他给该地区的居民贴上了印第安人的标签。他继续前进，相信自己很快就会偶然发现中国和日本。
In the centuries that followed his voyage, hundreds of cartographers and historians corrected his numerous mistakes. They mapped the Americas, documenting the lives of the indigenous people who had lived there for centuries, and the many harms that European visitors had done to these native groups. Where the Italian explorer was all swashbuckling daring do, they were careful and prized accuracy. In every era there are people like Christopher Columbus. They are the heroes and villains of our history books, the bulls in our china shops. They leap before they look, they take a grand or outlandish idea and run with it. They go out on limbs in pursuit of their
在他航行的几个世纪里，数百名制图师和历史学家纠正了他无数的错误。他们绘制了美洲地图，记录了在那里生活了几个世纪的原住民的生活，以及欧洲访问者对这些原住民造成的种种伤害。如果说这位意大利探险家充满了好勇斗狠的冒险精神，那么他们则谨慎并珍视准确性。在每个时代都有像克里斯托弗·哥伦布这样的人。他们是我们历史书中的英雄和恶棍，是我们瓷器店里的公牛。他们不假思索就采取行动，他们接受宏大或古怪的想法并付诸实践。为了追求自己的
ambitions. Sometimes they change the world for the better. Sometimes they're a disaster, a cautionary tale for the rest of us. Cartographers by contrast are careful, detail-oriented. They are the ones who pressure test the claims of the explorers, the ones who develop the detailed maps of the new worlds the explorers have haphazardly sketched for us. Cartographers often roll their eyes at the antics of explorers. Phil Zimbardo was an explorer. He wanted to answer a big question and make a splash while doing it. The pull of big provocative ideas was irresistible to him and his work continues to provoke conversations
雄心壮志，他们敢于冒险。有时他们让世界变得更美好。有时他们是一场灾难，是我们其余人的警世故事。相比之下，制图师是谨慎的、注重细节的。他们是那些对探险者的主张进行压力测试的人，是那些为我们绘制探险者草率勾勒的新世界详细地图的人。制图师常常对探险者的滑稽动作翻白眼。菲尔·津巴多就是一位探险者。他想回答一个宏大的问题，并在过程中引起轰动。宏大而挑衅性的想法对他有着不可抗拒的吸引力，他的工作继续引发人们对善恶本质的讨论。
about the nature of good and evil. But in his zeal to explore these big ideas, he was also reckless. He overlooked details and cut corners in the way he constructed his most famous experiment. He rode roughshod over the safety and concerns of the young volunteers who were ostensibly in his care. And yet, it is also true that he generated enormous public interest in psychology. In the late 1990s, when the internet was still in its infancy, I remember running a Google search for Stanford.
但在他热衷于探索这些宏大想法的同时，他也同样鲁莽。他在构建自己最著名的实验时忽视了细节，走了捷径。他对名义上受他照顾的年轻志愿者的安全和关切置若罔闻。然而，同样真实的是，他在心理学领域激发了公众巨大的兴趣。在20世纪90年代末，当互联网还处于婴儿期时，我记得我用谷歌搜索过“斯坦福”。
I wanted to look up the university directory for an expert I needed to interview. But the first result that popped up on my screen was not for the university. It was a link to the Stanford prison experiment. Phil helped his colleagues see that questions of morality were not merely philosophical questions, but scientific questions. The field of moral psychology is an extraordinarily robust area of study today.
我想查找我需要采访的一位专家的大学目录。但弹出的第一个结果不是大学主页。而是斯坦福监狱实验的链接。菲尔帮助他的同事们认识到，道德问题不仅仅是哲学问题，也是科学问题。今天，道德心理学领域是一个异常强劲的研究领域。
Phil also helped the general public recognize the value of psychology in answering some of the most pressing questions of our time. When we see genocides and mass murder around the world today, when we see human beings dehumanize one another, many of us no longer look for religious or theological explanations. We too ask ourselves the question that a boy once asked himself at a high school in the Bronx. What is it that prompts good people to do evil things? Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
菲尔还帮助广大公众认识到心理学在回答我们这个时代一些最紧迫问题时的价值。今天，当我们看到世界各地的种族灭绝和大规模谋杀，当我们看到人类彼此非人化时，我们中的许多人不再寻求宗教或神学解释。我们也开始问自己，布朗克斯一所高中的一个男孩曾经问过自己的那个问题。究竟是什么促使好人做出邪恶的事情？《隐藏的大脑》由“隐藏的大脑”传媒公司制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love our show, please help to support it. Join our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus, for ideas and interviews you won't hear anywhere else. Go to either apple.co. slash hiddenbrain or support.hiddenbrain.org. You'll be providing us with vital support
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请给予支持。加入我们的播客订阅“隐藏的大脑+”，获取你在其他地方听不到的想法和访谈。访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain 或 support.hiddenbrain.org。你们将为我们提供至关重要的支持，
to bring you many more episodes of Hidden Brain in the future. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以便我们在未来为您带来更多精彩的《隐藏的大脑》节目。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。回头见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。